digamos que x es una función del
parámetro tema y que es igual al coseno
de t y que también es una función de t y
es igual a la función seno de temp y lo
que queremos hacer es encontrar la
longitud de arco que tras la curva desde
t igual a 0 hasta que igual a pi medios
la longitud de arco que tras la curva
desde t igual a cero hasta t igual a pri
medios así que pausa el vídeo y ve si
puedes encontrar esta longitud de arco
basándote en las fórmulas que hemos
visto en los vídeos pasados
bien primero voy a pensar en la fórmula
y después lo voy a graficar para que
podamos ver que el resultado en efecto
es el que obtenemos de la fórmula así
que la fórmula que tenemos nos dice que
la longitud de arco la longitud de arco
dada por una curva paramétrica es igual
a
la integral definida desde t igual
hasta igual a b desde el punto inicial
de nuestro parámetro hasta el punto
final de nuestro parámetro de la raíz
cuadrada de quien de x prima de t esto
elevado al cuadrado más que prima de
tema
esto elevado al cuadrado y a esto lo
multiplicamos por dt y bueno esto
también se puede escribir como la
integral definida desde a avn
ok de la raíz cuadrada de la derivada de
x con respecto al tiempo al cuadrado más
la derivada de ye con respecto a t al
cuadrado y esto multiplicarlo por de
tema
pero en cualquiera de ambas podemos
aplicar este contexto bien primero
pensamos que no es la derivada de x con
respecto a t bueno la derivada de exxon
respecto al tema es la derivada del
coste no de tema con respecto al tema lo
cual es el menos seno de t perfecto y
ahora tienes la derivada de kiev con
respecto a t bueno la derivada de ye con
respecto a tm es la derivada del seno de
temps que es el coseno de t
entonces la longitud de arco que
buscamos va a ser igual a la integral
definida de 0 a pi medios de la raíz
cuadrada de que bueno de el menos seno
de tema pero aquí me queda esto elevado
al cuadrado entonces simplemente es el
seno cuadrado de t
más el cos en un cuadrado de t esto por
dt y ahora para nuestra suerte
sabemos que el seno cuadrado dt más el
coste no cuadrado de t es igual a 1 esta
es una de nuestras identidades
trigonométricas más importantes que
salen de la definición del círculo
unitario del seno y del coseno así que
tengo la raíz principal de bueno
simplemente 1 lo cual va a ser uno hace
que todo esto se simplifica solamente a
la integral de 0 a pi medios de dt y
bueno esto lo puedes ver simplemente
como la anti derivada de 1 si ponemos un
1 aquí y me quedaría la anti derivada
con respecto a td1 lo cual es
simplemente t
ok esto evaluado de pi medios a 0
entonces vamos a hacer la evaluación en
prime dios y a eso le vamos a restar la
evaluación en 0 por lo que simplemente
nos quedan primeros menos 0 lo cual es
y medios
bien ahora veamos por qué este resultado
que nos dio tiene sentido para eso vamos
a graficar esta curva este es mi eje
bien este es mi eje x y cuánto te es
igual a cero tenemos el punto coseno de
cero lo cual es 1 entonces x es igual a
1 y ya es el seno de 0 lo cual es 0
entonces que es 0 así que estamos en
este punto de aquí ente igual a 0 y si
te crece hasta pi medios entonces
tendremos la primera mitad de la parte
de arriba del círculo unitario y
terminaríamos aquí ente igual a pear
medios podemos verte como un cierto
ángulo en radiales así que la longitud
de arco va a ser simplemente la longitud
que hay en un cuarto de círculo y
nosotros ya sabemos cuánto vale el
perímetro de una circunferencia es 2 por
el radio pero en el círculo unitario el
radio es igual a 1 entonces la
circunferencia de todo el círculo
unitario es de 2 espn y un cuarto de eso
va a ser simplemente pi medios
de esta manera llegamos al mismo
resultado así que se ve muy elegante en
que todo esto que construimos en cálculo
es consistente con lo que aprendimos en
geometría básica hasta la próxima